ثقه المعلمين في تويتر تتراجع والارادات
الماديه خفضت بشكل كبير بعد تولي ايلون
ماسك القياده الرسميه للشركه وفق ما كشفته
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
كيلو 90 في المئه من عائدات تويتر التي
بلغت اكثر من خمسه مليارات دولار العام
الماضي الاعلانات في تويتر تراجعت خلال
مونديال قطر بعد ان كانت مباريات كاس
العالم تشكل فرصه ذهبيه لتدفق الدولارات
على الشركه ولكن هذه المره عائداتها من
الاعلانات في الولايات المتحده اصبحت اقل
بنسبه 80% عن التوقعات خلال الاسبوع
الراهن وفق ما اكده موظفون سابقون لتويتر
لصحيفه الامريكيه مشيرين الى ان ارادات
تويتر قبل تولي ماسك القياده كانت تدر
للشركه واحد فاصله اربعه مليار دو لكن
الرقم تراجع الى واحد فاصله ثلاثه مليار
دولار عند تسلمه تويتر ثم اصبح مليار
دولار فاصله واحد حاليا
فقدان الثقه بالشركه اثرت على المعلنين
الذين عبروا عن مخاوف كبيره تدور حول
سياسه ماسك الغامضه ماسك كان حذر بنفسه
مرارا وتكرارا من مواجهه شركته لدائقه
ماليه شديده دفعته الى اللجوء الى فرض
اشتراك شهري بقيمه ثمانيه دولارات على
كافه
المستخدمين محاسن حضاره العربيه